what was it about Bruce Lee that made
him such a martial-arts icon of course
Bruce brought an incredible screen
presence and deep philosophy to his
craft but beyond that what made him so
fascinating to watch sure Bruce was fast
but there have been plenty of super fast
martial artists Ennis and Bruce was
ripped but again no more so than many
others who came before after him so what
is it about Bruce's physicality that
really made him stand out and was he
really as invincible as many myths and
legends would have us believe I think I
have at least part of the answer and the
clue lies in his amazing one finger
push-up
but first if you guys enjoy this
philosophical approach to real worlds
training and performance you'll probably
get a kick out of my e-book and training
program super functional training
there's a discount on at the moment so
go and check it out if you're interested
that one finger push-up would be
impressive by any standards but if you
watch closely you'll notice that it's
even more impressive than it looks
unlike many people performing this move
or even just a one-handed push-up Bruce
does not move his hand to the center of
his body nor does he turn his body at
all his hand stays directly beneath the
shoulder while the rest of his body
remains perfectly straight and parallel
to the ground what does this show us it
shows that Bruce has insane core
stability he is able to resist the
rotational force to prevent his opposite
shoulder dipping even slightly while
also preventing any extension in his
spine nevermind the incredible finger
strength of this move also requires try
it for yourself and you'll see just how
amazing it is funny thing is that
Bruce's other signature moves also
demonstrate amazing cost ability in
particular
Bruce's dragon flag is a classic anti
extension move where the real challenge
is engaging the core to prevent the
buttocks from bending tours of ground
coincidence now check out Bruce
performing the V sit as an actual v6
like a gymnast would do not an l-sit and
that demonstrates not only impressive
strength but also mobility
this requires compressive strength which
is powering the core to bend that way
against natural resistance we see this
again when Bruce pancake stretches from
standing while warming up to fight Chuck
Norris but what does this have to do
with Bruce's ability to deliver such
watchable punches and kicks
well everything watch Bruce Lee throw a
punch and one thing stands out his upper
torso is rigid like a plank of wood
there's no wobble and no give this is
crucial for delivering truly powerful
blows as spine specialist stuart mcgill
put it proximal stiffness enhances
distal athleticism core stability is a
misunderstood concept but it essentially
describes the ability to keep the core
rigid and still against resistance this
can be broken down into the following
categories anti flexion resisting
bending forwards this is important when
squatting or dead lifting to prevent
rounding of the spine and thus injury
anti extension resisting bending
backwards this is what is key to the
Dragon Flag anti lateral flexion
resisting bending sideways if you press
just a single dumbbell with one hand
since you use anti lateral flection to
prevent tipping to one side anti
rotation resisting twisting key to the
100 push-up but also extremely important
in grappling this rigidity is what
allows a martial artist to translate to
power from their hips into a powerful
punch think about it this way if I were
to hit you with a plank of wood with a
nail on the end that would probably hurt
don't worry I wouldn't do that to you
but if that nail was attached to
something bendy like a thin branch it
would hurt a lot less not only that but
the trajectory of the nail would be
slower and less efficient to take the
rest of the quote from McGill when
muscles contract they try to shorten
consider the specific action here the
arm flexes around the shoulder joint
moving the arm from muscle shortening at
the distal end but the same shortening
also bends the ribcage towards the arm
at the proximal end of the muscle thus
simply using the PEC muscle would not
result in the fast nor forceful punch
now stiffen the proximal end of the PEC
muscle attachment meaning stiffen the
core and the ribcage that it can't move
now 100% of the PEC muscle shortening is
directed to action at its distal end
producing fast and forceful motion in
the arm in the same way a stiffened core
locks down the proximal ends of the hip
muscles producing faster leg motion a
loss of course stiffness causes the
torso to bend when sprinting and a loss
of speed some force was robbed that
should have been expressed in leg
velocity this way the rigidity of your
core will also result in greater
mobility and flexibility now watch Bruce
Lee again make sense right and we know
that Bruce absolutely prioritized core
training at some points performing his
ab routine daily Bruce also made the
point about contracting every muscle in
his body during training improving his
mind muscle connection and his power
I've shared Bruce is known AB routine in
the article that accompanies this video
you can follow the link in the
description down below to find that for
yourself this is not just kyun martial
arts this is true for all athletic
pursuits and it's one reason that
functional coaches spend a lot of time
building stability in their clients many
of these exercises involve keeping the
core completely stable or performing a
light unilateral or twisting movement to
provide challenge and to serve as a kind
of de-stress
often as soon as we forget about cost
ability it all goes to pieces however
you can simply use calisthenics moves
like the one-armed push-up the LaLanne
push-up and handstand push-ups to
develop something similar likewise you
can use the unilateral and offset
exercises like the suitcase carry and
other one-sided loaded carries likewise
when performing any movement from the
squat to the humble press up be mindful
of what your core is doing and whether
you're able to keep it rigid during that
movement
don't let the waist sag or the upper
background core stability is also so
important for Vance calisthenics I found
that when performing freestanding
handstands core stability is critical to
getting the straight line the minute my
spine goes into extension I have two
choices
banana handstand or bail the ability to
straighten up again is the difference
between success and failure so what's
the takeaway start using those anti
moves in your own training and you'll
see improvements in every area of your
athleticism I've developed a short core
stability workout that I'm posting to
Instagram you can incorporate these
moves into your existing workouts or
swap this with your current abs day go
and follow me on instagram at to the bio
near to check that out for yourself the
link will be in the description down
below one more thing
think about investing in a chair with no
back when you sit in an office your
spine is artificially supported for
hours on end this can cause the deep
muscles of the core to actually switch
off and eventually we lose some of that
tone and conscious control over them so
thanks ton for watching this one guys
hope found it useful and interesting let
me know what you think could this be one
of the keys to Bruce Lee's speed and
power do you guys use core stability
training in your own routines
looking forward to hearing what you guys
have to say and I hope you're all
staying healthy and safe I'll see you
next time thanks time for watching and
bye for now